so this is what it is how would you
prove it the boring way and the you know
the talk way is you take this guy and
you can expend it's not hard but one of
the things that you guys need to be very
very material is the fact that there's
always more than one way to do something
okay so think about this with me if I
told you don't expand if I told you come
up with some other way to prove it what
would you do stop for a second think
about it because some of you will
immediately see another way or some of
you might already haven't told another
way I want to give the rest of us some
thinking time to catch up you think of
another relatively easy way to prove it
Darce your hen ring up I retract my
offer okay Nikki it's a couple of
different I see this yeah
at a b2 what you mean here on this side
so I'm gonna consider this guy's plus a
B okay say it again
okay see what he did see really good
this is a similar thing to completing
the square isn't it and actually this is
a very important trick when you're we're
learning as we will learn a lot more
trigonometric identities what are the
main tricks that they pull out of their
hat is to say how do you how do you go
from this side to this side
you sometimes have to add something and
subtract it straight away okay all the
way up until like oh extension to harder
integration one of the hardest kinds on
recurrence relations really really hard
calculus and they rely on this simple
trick it's often very hard to see anyone
you know what should I choose to add in
subtract where you gonna go from here
okay now I can factorize kana what
should I take out I can pair up a from
this so it'll be a plus B and then good
and there it is you can see it now
excellent
okay I'm happy with that
good you need to push yourself a little
bit okay think about who you are don't
just settle for one answer but just
settle for that way is often a way that
takes another route and it might be more
profound more insightful let me give you
one more because it's um it's one of my
favorites which is a squared minus B
squared why do you call it squared why
don't we say to the power two because
that's what it is
why is it squaring and why is it cubing
and why don't some power 4 have a
special name actually [ __ ] yeah if I
gave you a square of side length a right
then area would be a squared cuz it's a
square and if you went three dimensions
it's a which one do I want cute cuz it's
cubed and if I went four dimensions I
guess it would be a tesseract him I know
that's that's a four dimensional okay so
if it's a swear that's what it really
means if that's what this really means
what does this thing look like it looks
like a square minus another square
that's square-ish right okay so a
squared minus B squared if I say this is
a square
on the outside and this is B squared on
the inside where is a squared minus B
square on that diagram yeah it's this
sum it's this quarter plug here the L
shape rotated L shape okay sir
how shall I work our kids area it's not
so hard
there's lots of ways to do this but a
way that's parallel to what we did
algebraically here with this suggestion
is well just have a look at this part up
here I'll share write that L shape it's
a composite area tell me the area of the
blue part okay
it's a across that way hey times what's
this it might be good because longer
side - shorter side okay we have another
area they don't owe me this guy down the
bottom what's that equal to
that's going to be B B times a minus B
again it's the same there's a symmetry
to it it's rotational symmetry so so
there you go that's a squared minus B
squared a squared minus B squared is
equal to the blue plus the red which
looks to me similar but not quite you
see how we factorize that we've paired
it the other way but you're still going
to get the same thing okay all right
familiar results some unfamiliar ways to
get there difference of squares that's a
bit pedestrian let's move up to this guy
difference of cubes
now the handy thing with the difference
of cubes is that if you're trying to
work out the difference here that's 1
cubed minus another one I think what's
neat is that you can also do the Sun
don't shine out to me but raise your
hand is you know these results you've
memorized and hair straight up yeah
let's go hands down we'll all need to
get there but for now let's do this and
I'll show you the way that I do I do min
in parallel and it's very easy to
remember okay you're gonna need two sets
of brackets in both cases
okay the factorization that goes into
each of these follows this pattern a B a
squared and that patterns gonna repeat a
these same pieces same order okay now
what joins us all together is all of the
operations right it's all series of
pluses and minuses okay and in a second
I'm gonna ask you to verify them by
doing taking the suggestion you had in
the beginning which is just to look at
that and then expand okay it's
sufficiently complicated that I won't
make you do another way but how do you
get the science right how do you get the
signs right mr. Ewing is usually yeah
okay good so so this is the acronym that
I prefer for this one and I learnt it
after I left school will be really
useful so it stands for same opposite
always positive is there are three signs
okay so watch first sign okay it's gonna
be the same as whatever your factorizing
the same the next one will be the
opposite which in this case will us and
then the last one regardless of what
your factorizing is pure waste positive
same opposite always wasn't very easy
result and you can use it just simply
for the son of cubes same opposite
always positive okay
I'd like you to go ahead and verify it
both of these let's call this one for
Emma number one sorry Nemo - go ahead
as with any proof of an identity okay
you can't start with saying this because
that's assuming what you're trying to
prove instead the way you want to set it
out this is like so go from one side to
the other this time mandating which way
I want you to go I want you to go from
right to left okay so take these expand
them out and verify that everything
cancels and you arrive back at your song
or difference